R
THE FEDERAL WORKFORCE.
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT PETER
DOOCY STARTS US OFF TONIGHT LIVE
ON THE NORTH LAWN.
GOOD EVENING, PETER.
>> GOOD EVENING, BRET.
FOR THE FIRST TIME SINCE MAY
WALKING THROUGH THE PRESSROOM TO
GET OUT HERE TO THE LIVE SHOT
POSITION, EVERYBODY INSIDE IS
WEARING A MASK.
THE VICE PRESIDENT HOSTED AN
EVENT LATE THIS AFTERNOON, SHE
KEPT A MASK ON THE WHOLE TIME.
SO DID EVERYBODY ELSE IN THE
BUILDING AS NEW SIGNS ARE GOING
UP INSIDE THE WHITE HOUSE THAT
SAY MASKS ARE NOW REQUIRED EVEN
FOR THE FULLY VACCINATED THAT IS
TO COMPLY WITH THE NEW CDC
GUIDANCE.
>> THIS IS NOT A DECISION THAT
WE AT CDC HAVE MADE LIGHTLY.
THIS WEIGHS HEAVILY ON ME.
>> Peter: PRESIDENT BIDEN SAYS
MORE VACCINATIONS AND
MASK-WEARING IN THE AREAS MOST
IMPACTED BY THE ALAN DERSHOWITZ
WILL ENABLE US TO AVOID THE KIND
OF LOCKDOWNS, SHUTDOWNS, SCHOOL
CLOSURES AND DISRUPTIONS WE
FACED IN 2020.
UNLIKE 2020, WE HAVE BOTH THE
SCIENTIFIC KNOWLEDGE AND THE
TOOLS TO PREVENT THE SPREAD OF
THIS DISEASE.
WE ARE NOT GOING BACK TO THAT.
BUT, HE IS STILL SEARCHING FOR
WAYS TO REACH THE UNVACCINATED.
>> IF THOSE OH 100 MILLION
PEOPLE GOT VACCINATED WE WOULD
BE IN A VERY DIFFERENT WORLD.
SO GET VACCINATED.
IF YOU HAVEN'T [INAUDIBLE]
>> AND IF PEOPLE WHO WORK FOR
THIS COUNTRY'S LARGEST EMPLOYER,
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AREN'T
VAXXED, THAT MAY SOON BE
REQUIRED.
>> IT'S UNDER CONSIDERATION
RIGHT NOW.
>> THIS MAP SHOWS AREAS MOST
IMMEDIATELY AFFECTED BY TODAY'S
MASKING UPDATE.
COUNTIES WITH SUBSTANTIAL OR
HIGH COVID-19 TRANSMISSION.
>> SUBSTANTIAL IS ORANGE AND
HIGH IS RED.
>> AND WHEN IT'S TIME TO GO BACK
TO SCHOOL.
>> CDC RECOMMENDS THAT EVERYONE
IN K THROUGH 12 SCHOOLS WEAR A
MASK INDOORS INCLUDING TEACHERS,
STAFF, STUDENTS, AND VISITORS
REGARDLESS OF VACCINATION
STATUS.
>> Peter: THAT'S GOING TO BE A
TOUGH SELL IN SOME STATES.
>> I CAN TELL YOU THE FOLKS BACK
HOME ARE DONE WITH MASKS.
IF YOU HAVE BEEN VACCINATED OR
HAD THE VIRUS I DON'T SEE THE
SCIENCE BEHIND INSISTING PEOPLE
WEAR MASK.
>> CDC ARGUES THE VACCINATED MAY
NOT GET SICK BUT THEY CAN
SPREAD.
>> SOME VACCINATED PEOPLE
INFECTED WITH THE DELTA VARIANT
AFTER VACCINATION MAY BE
CONTAGIOUS AND SPREAD THE VIRUS
TO OTHERS.
>> AND WITH THAT, TODAY'S
GUIDANCE REPRESENTS ANOTHER STEP
BACKWARDS.
>> WHY DID THE PRESIDENT SAY IF
YOU HAVE BEEN FULLY VACCINATED
YOU NO LONGER NEED TO WEAR A
MASK.
LET ME REPEAT.
>> LET ME REPEAT, IF YOU ARE
FULLY VACCINATED, YOU NO LONGER
NEED TO WEAR A MASK?
>> IF IT WAS POSSIBLE THAT THAT
WAS GOING TO TURN OUT NOT TO BE
TRUE.
>> WELL, PETER, I THINK WE ARE
ALL DEALING WITH AN EVOLVING
VIRUS WHERE THERE IS NO PLAYBOOK
AND NO HISTORIC PRECEDENT.
>> Peter: GUIDANCE AMOUNTS TO
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
REALIZING THAT UNVACCINATED
PEOPLE ARE STILL GETTING SICK
AND THEN ADMITTING THAT EVEN IF
YOU GOT THE SHOT AND DID
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT THEY ASKED
YOU TO DO SINCE THEY TOOK
OFFICE, SIX MONTHS AGO SO, THAT
SOME DAY YOU COULD DITCH THE
MASK, THEY DON'T THINK IT WAS
ENOUGH.
BRET?
>> Bret: WHAT ABOUT THE
LEGALITY, PETER, FOR EMPLOYERS
TO REQUIRE PEOPLE, WORKERS, TO
GET VACCINATED?
>> Peter: THE BIDEN DOJ LOOKED
AT THIS.
THEY THINK THAT IS LEGAL.
THE OFFICE OF LEGAL COUNSEL AT
THE DOJ COLLECTED TO SEE IF
THESE PEOPLE WHO CHALLENGED
VACCINE MANDATES BECAUSE THE
VACCINE -- BECAUSE THE VACCINES
STILL ARE NOT FDA APPROVED AND
USING EMERGENCY AUTHORIZATION
CAN OPT OUT AND KEEP THEIR JOBS.
THE DOJ'S UNDERSTANDING OF THE
FOOD, DRUG AND COSMETIC ACT IS
THAT SUCH VACCINE MANDATES ARE
LEGAL.
MEMOS LIKE THIS ARE NOT LEGALLY
BINDING BUT WE CAN EXPECT THEM
TO BE FOLDED INTO COURT
CHALLENGES TO COM